did you guys hear taiko YTD is directing
a new Star Wars film really what's it
about no idea oh I guess that's all for
that movie news story may the 4th be
with you Japs we're gonna watch the day
from cinema wins everything great about
Star Wars Episode nine the rise of
Skywalker part 1 apparently you know
with all that reception surprises
Skywalker but this being made the 4th I
figured you know what let's celebrate
the good that was in Raisa Skywalker
before we do that I want to thank
everyone who voted on my Twitter at the
Greg a but of how I should start star
wars the clone wars it had been awhile
since I watched any of the show so I
wanted to just start fresh again thank
you guys for voting over there and I
started it up again as of yesterday way
behind now that the show is over
I need to catch up before the
Mandalorian season to comes back
speaking of TV shows go over to our
patreon page if you come up a project
today over there we have a weekly Q&A
podcast and we do TV show reaction watch
alongs where you sync up with a timecode
but we also have the option for reaction
highlights included and those shows are
supernatural Doctor Who JoJo's bizarre
adventures just started that up attack
on Titan death note my hero academia
fully caught up over there to heros
movie included Code Geass Hunter hunter
one punch man bull Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and promised Neverland and
then there are shows we only do the
watcher longs for them agents of shield
Gotham the Mandalorian Cobra Kai season
2 stranger things season 3 Game of
Thrones black mirror and haunting of
Hill House become a patron ejected a
people long ass intro was done let's do
this
long ass reaction feels like a good time
to briefly remind you my dear viewers
what this channel is about well it
started out a lot more tongue-in-cheek
it quickly became obvious to me that bad
movies had fans who enjoyed them on
ironically so slowly the bad
I'm pretending it's good [ __ ]
disappeared and I went looking for more
sincere points although you guys know
preparing a few here there I do argue
against and defend perceived problems
but unless I come right out and say it
the winds aren't about judging whether a
movie is good or bad that's just not
what I'm interested in doing with this
channel my mission statement has become
every movies at least one person's
favorite try to figure out the reasons
why there's positive to the right I like
that I'm that person okay
favorite is a big word but my point is
that I'm making this video for me I
enjoyed this movie and if one more
person feels like they can be honest
about enjoying it this is hey the
support group how's a great intro that's
a great intro
[Music]
well they're just coming right out with
it he's back it seems like your
enjoyment of this movie could very
easily boil down to that one plot point
because yomo changes on it
I guess I'd say pretend for watched you
that it's what you wanted and see how
you feel
call me in the morning I'm going to look
at this out of the way I know it it's
not what a lot of you wanted I wouldn't
say it's what I wanted but here we are
also a bold move to go back to the
Phantom Menace but like yeah how he's
been the fans of control yet from one
through nine it's a saber forum where
you just drag the lightsaber through
their shoulder that's pretty cool this
one is always on point comparator we
know the sound of like electricity and
lightning are made creepy and foreboding
very true I have this image of his cult
followers pumping out a snow clone he's
not ready his face is all messed up we
need more time there's no nursing staff
to staff to many abilities some consider
to be
let's just say hearing Ian McDermott see
that line again a line we all agree
comes from arguably the best scene in
the prequels definitely yep complain
about the imperial marks with a bunch of
starter stories writing out of the ice
sheets simply the way these two actors
interact and talk over each other it's
volunteering showing off galaxies
visually pretty cool funny you should
say that there's definitely a moral
ethical gray area here but listening to
carries daughter Billy talk about how
she thinks carry would have loved to be
the focus of this movie even
posthumously nice to give them credit
for seamlessly weaving extra footage
from the force awakens into this movie
it's one of those times where outside
knowledge can break suspension of
disbelief but they did just about
everything they could to combat it and
gave Carey and Leia a decent final
chapter I'm bringing this up just to say
they're probably gonna leave a lot of
these inconsistencies alone yes before
the nomination individual dictionary
came out I assume Dre and Leia fixed
Luke / Anakin's lightsaber with some
force magic you know the way they do
remember everything in Star Wars
Ryan specifically left it open-ended
but just writing down after the fact
that they healed the Kyber crystal with
force magic doesn't mean a better in
movie explanation shouldn't have been
given or any in movie explanation or
that maybe something should matter and
should it be undone here carlo was
taking one last to make sure it wasn't
better speaking to him by the way the
emperor does a really good Andy Serkis
James Earl Jones impression very
completely off her game it turns her
into a lumberjack which I approve up not
an environmentalist man removed actually
it's even sadder like when you
accidentally step on your dog's tail and
they're all submissive like they think
they're being punished and you can't
apologize enough also I like the
confirmation that since in the last Jedi
Snoke says he connected them it means
Palpatine actually connected them it
clearly can't be undone
somehow Palpatine returned with some
cult members used some stiff magic to
raise him but he's back and it doesn't
matter he's always been just the symbol
of evil his backstory never mattered in
the OT and the PT only fleshed out his
rise to power as it pertained to
Anakin's fall more on all that later
oh okay mods when talking about race
lineage did say this in the force
awakens then never coming back there's
someone who still could point
well if there was one theme in these
movies that seems to carry through every
trilogy its masters telling their
Padawans that they're not ready and then
the Padawans going somewhere or doing
something anyway
I need to go alone definition good
advice especially coming from Vader's
daughter / kylo ren's mom and yet in the
feeling I need to go back and yep that
is Leia's blockade runner back with her
again okay I personally love the Kyle
gets his helmet back but there is a
definite undertone from the ninth and
grand if you want back in mascot so not
only are the Knights of Ren evil they're
also space polluters aliens for now like
that doesn't just was broken he embraces
it with bright red welds which is based
on consuming the Japanese art of fixing
cracks and pottery with gold lacquer my
take on it oh really
because something is fixed doesn't mean
it was never broken so why pretend goals
as in seagulls you beautiful stick
offense isn't like a cult somebody get
this guy a copy of New Hope note are
gonna save you this time
Applewhite win cuties yeah like a lot of
things in this movie thing were
practical little dudes
I miss you Threepio
the same way at least for this trilogy
it's the first time this galaxy feels
lived-in again yeah things going on that
don't have to do with our heroes even
maz kanata's place in the force awakens
fella you know that's a good perspective
to have and again all the natives are
practical people in suits doing the
dances the kids are puppets controlled
by three puppeteers each you mean the
last time it was happening was right
around the time Luke saw his sister's r2
recording and then they broke star wars'
[Music]
do you need to help hitting on anyone
[Music]
we've always been sorta able to tell
what r2 and Chewie are saying based on
responses but I feel like you can often
almost hear bb-8 actual words and if
you're wondering how bb-8 knew the
canisters would be helpful you notice
them earlier planted that's the action
really is cool in this favourites cutoff
here but if 1% makes sense that nonsense
wouldn't want any old scavenger to
translate a SIF map in unleash darkness
on with a galaxy accidentally it
wouldn't be Star Wars without a big
monster of some kind I know the new
force ability for the movies but you
probably noticed that Ray's been reading
the old texts and you really think the
Jedi didn't have a horse version of tier
3 or maybe brainwash them in wool here
was again trying to confirm what the
Emperor said by pulling the Palpatine
power out of her so first he assumed
she'd do something I'm sure and if she
didn't oh well she wasn't with the
trouble that read it seemed mad that
he'd risk it but every single lightsaber
duel is a risk that someone is going to
die forced users take that risk of
Compton and I don't want to call the OL
it's just a metaphor bro but this is
also a look at the dark side versus the
light side thus it will smash through
you while the Jedi like to get the high
ground to flip easy there's no more
goofy than the spin move during his duel
with Vader hey I never noticed they
didn't get coverage over them doing from
this angle
obi-wan is just preparing to die before
he's prepared to die anyway
[Music]
at any cost sighs skinny little girl
taking out a Thai silencer combine it
with this it's simply there to
illustrate the divider and suffering
thing also I guess I was wrong about her
beating OB ones ascendant okay so
apparently JJ said he felt that the
thing time to tell ray was that he was
force sensitives
so fine okay but how was it not that fin
knew she was Palpatine's granddaughter
he says this leader shows Leia and we
find out even later because your apology
Leia knew it too so I'm going with that
just gonna pretend like JJ forgot is
that there are lots of death without
hands movie but only 120 seconds have
passed so it meant to be a trick on the
audience of any meaning just a quick way
for Ray to have some serious perceived
consequences for losing control if you
accidentally shoot you're actually just
more Jango Fett close ha Ray said he'd
do the same just transfer a bit of life
just look at his pretty face before you
commit to murdering him well he was can
do this all night true yeah buddy poet
okay making new friends
EDA compliant ramp for droids if
anyone's earned a cameo
I did not realize that was a chore
Willie it's always a win especially
voiced by Moaning Myrtle who controlled
his robotic mouth and eyes with a remote
controller I had no idea so cool using
his own thing against him I gotta admit
this is like doctor/patient really the
perfect video to watch today seriously
Bob it was amazing
shall we destroy the city a little Vader
a little hon evil Threepio is not
something I knew I wanted but I'm glad
seared into my memory now like yeah it's
an insane thing to give him but hear me
out the galaxy isn't getting better so
escaping fujimi probably won't pay much
for the weak-minded which is the
smartest distraction slash insult ever
not you you're too smart
raise here spot it's been studying Shree
work
[Music]
[Music]
juhi miss being called scum Nicky said
yes I was wrong about obi-wan and his
British accent being connected Dre but
yes so I was still right Jul through
space you can tell was filmed with both
backdrops and it brings you into the
craziness they're both experiencing by
the way ray is trained now and kylo is
still basically toying with her this
time he hasn't been gutshot by castor
[Music]
the road answer to two questions why she
badass and how she nobody the other part
is Finn having force powers being a Jedi
is still open to anyone but to play in
this story that's always been about
bloodlines you gotta have one beg to
differ
so the dagger lining up generally does
work because Threepio does say this is
the stretch okay depends of the
indefensible the Death Star was built to
exist in space therefore any elements
within an atmosphere including crashing
waves aren't going to erode the outer
shell and the idea is that it's so
massive nothing is gonna shift its
position so thirty years later the
dagger might still why not
you know I forgot how cool this movie
looks how does I note the hollowed-out
giant space station is on point again
and for me this holds onto the Wayfinder
is another torch
I don't Moses years later here's the
period marked only on strings from when
Luke took his mask off the only one who
can smell dead Death Star wait that door
open because she's about to it was
clearly a secret room after all all
right probably not what you were
picturing both there's the double-sided
seer you all asked for how about you two
getting a final confrontation in the
place both of their grandfathers had a
final confrontation with their Jedi
Master so we get superhero landings all
the time but these are force landings
sure we would like these to Dan that
sound design is even not fully present
still like really girl fighting the
prequels I always love the raw emotion
of sequel duels visually this is one of
my favorite tools Steve from the brain
and smashing waves the sound of the
sabers on the metal and again it works
as the climax of this conflict between
sift and Jedi on top of the wreckage of
the Death Star the stretching of the
laser giving way to the force
also there is a switch where kylo
actually becomes more composed again and
forces Rey to tire herself out
continuing to prove that on a technical
level she's no match brand her an
actress that didn't film any new scenes
for this movie Leia still gets an
impactful moment and I love the through
line that led us here
Leia tells Han not to give up on their
son which leads to his death she then
tells Luke that she knows he's gone but
Luke says no one's ever really gone and
now here we are for her last act one
that would believably kill her given
that she abandoned her training way
before Luke and his force projection
killed him I can't like quantifiably
prove it but it seems commensurate but
just her one word snaps Ben out of
meeting kylo Ren and I understand why it
would seem not like an act of love
because they stabbed him but that wasn't
Leah's goal she couldn't have predicted
Rey's actions she just wanted her son to
feel her presence one last time and make
sure he didn't kill ray she was a
weakness for him in the last Jedi and
before this fight he confessed that he
thought he could never go home he can't
go back watching a Leia break down
moment made this whole video force ghost
Ben solo was finally seen kylo ren's
final confrontation with his dad from
Ben's perspective
Hans last act was to touch his son's
face in an act of love and forgiveness
this is Ben finally realizing what all
that meant that Han didn't get tricked
into this he expected it it didn't
matter he'd do anything to reach his son
and even after Leia was shaken she chose
the same it's an unconditional love that
parents have for their children and it's
the antithesis of the relationships that
SIF masters have with their apprentices
kylo couldn't see that when he was lost
to the dark side Wow
sacrifice to bring Ben solo back this
isn't meant to be as complicated as I've
seen people make it love his Ben's
motivation from here on out his dad
showed him love in the force awakens his
mom did here and now that the blinders
have been lifted he realizes there's
only one person left who loves him of
course she's gonna go help ray he was
wanted to defeat the Emperor anyway but
that's clearly no longer his motivation
he wants the safe ray even if it kills
him kick you stupid Oscar Adam know what
that dad from Ben really meant and
leaving the Isle of Mull instead
actually adds even more weight to the
time he said it to Leia it wasn't cocky
it was understanding it was connection
something then it lost to the dark side
Hey really really persuaded me out a
couple of things the tree with horse
lightning who projected himself across
the galaxy now Luke catches the
lightsaber
we know that r2 is an important place
for the force so it stands to reason
strong force location strong force goes
by our solution that his weapon deserves
more respect even though I was hard on
Mark Hamill in my last Jedi video mostly
well did he get this moment I understand
the playing of character and building up
who he is in your own mind to have it
I'm done with something you think
outside the realm of acceptability for
that character I stood over the record
it would be hard and we'll figure out
him one last narky comment Yoda has
always had an outside-the-box approached
all things force related no Luke those
two I'm never leaving this place I'm
doing what you did I was wrong
please don't start on me on how that is
a contradiction Luke realized he was
wrong at the end of the last Jenner
great boy great [ __ ] boy you should
have watched this video a long time ago
about it until now
Leia's theme in the foreground or what
looks like the middle of the storm yet
they're still calm and collected it's
quick Syrio otherworldly and I'd watch
an entire series about Luke training
Leia
I've been keeping my cool here for the
most part but this got me in theaters
getting to see Luke not try but doing
the very thing he believed was
impossible and the reason he failed all
set to the same Yoda in the fourth score
one of my favorites from all of Star
Wars and again for life we need supposed
to hold on the new this month at movies
one in a million
okay that was a little extra Winky at
the audience but at least the universe
is unbroken now one wins the
visualization of the emperor's temple as
if the structure suspended off the
ground classic Star Wars misdirection
the hope wait are they in space no no
Poe did say the ships couldn't escape
ammo a couple times last battle on the
main destroyer with a ground fight in
the aerial battle the background
actually makes it less chaotic
I don't know that this meteor does then
run like a year
[Laughter]
run like a hero Oh thing about this
story thread I've been building towards
these two using their connection to work
together for two movies now and it's a
fulfillment of something I couldn't even
put into words at first the idea that
the connection between the two then was
more powerful than Snoke who had no idea
what was happening and now the same of
Palpatine the diet is something special
that you don't see often and it's
another correction the forces trying to
make to bring balance back to the force
[Music]
[Music]
probably hate his turn and loved it as
kylo Ren depends the holo alive now a
showcase of drivers of talent between
these two disparate characters that Han
shrug he is a solo nonchalant this is
the thing we do I'm glad we all seem to
agree Adam driver is amazing also yep
and now sorry I'm not surprised that the
actual sit slashed get I whatever he is
now the only force powerful warrior
using a lightsaber and made quick work
up please now just like guys with the
cool weapons of mass
[Music]
can copy you must have downgraded your
Victorians because none of these ones
have been able to disappear weapon from
their hand with your cold dead heart
this is how Star Wars is light versus
dark that's it almost every ship that
ever star wars not gonna look a gift
about me fricking the mouth but you're
bringing him into a battle yeah I'm sure
it's more sensitive and if you're
wondering how Zoe got off the G me
without that token there's a little
confusion obviously getting onto and off
of Kazemi is not hard since the Falcon
landed there no problem Dory says picked
up enough to get out I'm going to the
colonies and Poe says how all those High
Plains blocked nothing was stopping her
or anyone from leaving just from going
to colonies
Oh from the first moment I heard it in
force awakens' race team has been one of
my favorites and it's juxtaposition to
the darkness and defeat here makes it
stand out in the best possible way
Anakin qui-gon Yoda
kanan jarrus Aayla Secura obi-wan mace
all gone but all telling her to rise it
just works for me Luke throwing his
saber away I feel the need to remind you
that Luke had anakin to Bank his Rifa
rays only go well the other Jedi force
ghosts but she doesn't actually attack
she only deflects the emperor's
lightning back at him Oh we'll have a
little pride man named Falcon to the
rescue again
[Music]
see what you think about the kiss Ren
theme still holding bend down as the
score rises an anticipation I don't
actually think this is the answer here
but it is possible then could have read
the same text a trader during his time
with Luke but the force is less about
magic incantations waving your wand and
correct pronunciations that's been the
theme of this trilogy which I know upset
some people didn't bother me because
that's always how I've seen it that's
what you were lifting the x-wing out of
the swamp was about Ray had heard
stories about Ted I mind tricks so after
kylo opened her up to feeling the forest
she embraced that same feeling and tried
it out ray healed Ben so Ben knew was an
ability to force offered and he used it
knowing full well he'd have to transfer
all his life force energy to Rey
[Music]
spiritual connection that probably
doesn't have an equivalent for us kylo
and now Ben has always been drawn to her
metals retcon is your poison based are
we showing it off to Threepio though
what about you
that's fun it's his daughter
I know Billy Dee can't turn off his
animal magnetism it's not his fault
triple hugging our three heroes in front
of the Falcon Chewie Threepio and r2
under the wing of Luke's x-wing
labrets beam was almost a pensive
Skywalker theme building up underneath
Rey back to her roots sliding down a
sand hill back to Star Wars roots
tobogganing yep quite gold saber made
from her staff lending her scavenger
past with her Jedi future also any of
the novelization says it's one-sided but
it also says it's the inverse of dark
rays which was double-sided hey I'm the
section of her staff they used is pretty
symmetrical there's no spitting out on
the bottom stone so going frame by frame
shows a green and then blue always been
more important you choose who you want
to be I've got a few more thoughts about
that for later people were confused why
bb-8 wouldn't have stayed with poe and i
just took this to mean that Ray was
gonna come back I know the movie is over
but maybe this time you three could work
together create some kind of democratic
system that can't immediately be taken
over by the Sith again so yeah it was
hopeful for me like Poe was busy hitting
on Zoe so bb-8 went in a little job ray
and obviously one more end where we
began with our double stones on Tatsu
future there's a card up there with part
two in it will also be in the
description but almost 30 minutes and I
didn't get to the conclusion at all I
have written and I'm still kind of
organizing it so I'm hoping to have that
by the end of next week I thought this
was great into the trilogy into the
trilogy as well as how it fits in with
the rest of the numbered movies so
here's to hoping that I don't enough
cutting all of that and make this a lie
I'm fairly confident won't happen
bold move you might be thinking to do
two part video for a movie that nobody
but me liked that's just how I'm rolling
right now movie that's 10 years old that
I really like that nobody saw but I
promise you'll like it
and then another one
everybody hated but I liked it I don't
know what's going on in a why I'm doing
this hey I though that was great yeah I
really did definitely brought some
appreciation to places and you know all
things considered at the time of
watching this and this just went up
today which has made the for it's at
80,000 views and it has which I'm sure
in real time has a lot more views 9.5 K
likes and 505 dislikes so I'd say that
you're not alone here buddy all right
let's talk about some of these points
I'd be curious to go back and watch this
movie after watching this one now to see
how much of the perspective you've taken
with this has influenced my mind and my
viewing experience it seems like when
you saw this that you were able to
really see what they were going for
you're able to see it from the filmmaker
and the writing perspective of things I
think when you're slowing it down and
breaking it down what these scenes are
going for it's easier to latch on to
what the meaning and intention is behind
all this you know since there's other
things that factor into a viewing
experience such as you know pacing and
all that which can hide ya which can
like really get in the cloud away and
like even brought up a point about what
the usage of laya of how sometimes
knowing behind the scenes stuff can
interfere with viewing experience and I
wonder how much of that does play into
the recent experience with this trilogy
especially after the last Jedi all those
Kathleen Kennedy talks them keep coming
out to this day this woman is horrible
at her job she does not care anything
about Star Wars in any capacity
whatsoever
and then of course you know with rise of
Skywalker there's a lot of things here
that when I hear it in this format I
find my mindset and heart being
influenced and going you know I never
saw it like that you know it's actually
a really good point I want to focus on
some things that I definitely feel I'm
now changing my opinion on matter
because I think that's the most fun
thing about watching a video that's
either cinemasins or cinema wins it seem
like you know I'm a little bit persuaded
into viewing this a bit differently now
yeah I think everything you pointed out
about like technical stuff sound design
and what
not the way everything looks like this
film is so cool-looking and like the
action is so great the sound design is
so awesome that everything on a
technical scale it's it's I feel like a
pain of the day it's a film you can at
least go back on and go it's still a lot
of fun and really cool to look at
despite some storytelling flaws that
people might perceive I mean the whole
thing with Leia would always read a bit
strange to me and I know got a lot of
criticism I really think you've opened
up my mind a lot to how the movie wasn't
ending all this ago here I screenshot at
it I try to read it Leia tells Han not
to give up on her son which leads to his
death she then tells Luke that she knows
he's gone Balu says no one's ever really
gone she was a weakness for him in the
last Jedi before this fight he confessed
that he thought he can never go home and
now here we are for her last act one
that would believably kill her given
that she had been at her training way
before Luke and his force projection
killed him she just wanted her son to
feel her presence one last time and make
sure he didn't kill Rey all those
arguments brought up there's nothing
more I can really add to that because I
just think that it's so well but it's so
well articulated that does make sense
there was that thing established in the
last Jedi work then is very hesitant to
kill Leia on the ship the fact that she
didn't complete her training how her
using that force projection and just
wanting to connect with her son one last
time of this person who's always having
faith and hope in kylo honestly I
thought that was really moving and very
beautiful and the way you put it
completely changed my perspective on
that scene it made me really appreciate
it and how that led to what Rey doing
what she stabs him is like the symbolism
of your killing kylo Ren and you're
bringing Ben solo back and then
everything preceding after that right up
to Han scene was Ben solo now reliving
that final moment with Han seeing it
from the Ben solo perspective and not
the kylo Ren influenced by Sith
perspective I've said it many times nine
times out of ten I'm not a fan of
someone seeing ghost dad I usually find
that to be a cheap arc trick but the way
that it's bringing it full circle from
force awakens to this and then really
showcasing that it's gone from kylo Ren
to Ben solo I think is very powerful
very beautiful so literally all my
criticisms for that are now completely
on your side
yeah I'll say I have been moved and
persuaded with that section alone
I wonder how this will play on a second
viewing of the movie because this did
open up some things that you know you
probably would get distracted by
plotting and again hype and stuff like
that and this made me think back to what
George Lucas apparently said when he was
doing prequels which was this idea that
he wanted the different you know
chapters of the story to have a sort of
musical quality where they harmonized
with each other and I know a lot of
people have been very down on JJ Abrams
for repeating things and for borrowing
wholesale plot points I think there are
many ways you can still complain about
that however I thought this video did a
really nice job of highlighting those
moments within this particular movie and
across the whole series even things like
Luke lifting the x-wing in his you know
force ghost form you know harkening back
to the original films and stuff like
that showing the world as being more
lived-in and yeah this did help me to
appreciate at least in context at least
in what the story was about maybe more
so than what actually happened on-screen
but yeah those ideas that Leia and Han
are just trying to reach their son with
that love and yeah it goes to that
Harmony point of them we see that scene
again in the harmony and the more
beautiful side of it where Ben can just
take his father in I also like the
things that they pointed out about how
like we see certain Force abilities
demonstrated so if we give the
characters enough credit they probably
could figure those things out yeah yeah
just the general attention to just yeah
the the human side of the characters is
what I think this video did a really
nice job at and I like the idea I don't
think it's in the movie there at all but
that Finn to an extent like Leia and
some of the other people are trying to
get it that they sense the Palpatine in
Rey and that's what they're trying
that's what he's trying to tell her or
whatever again it just feels like love
to me but again I like the perspectives
that you brought to this video a lot
more than just some of the strain it
picks for me especially I mean if you go
back to the reviews I clearly felt like
there were things that they were
obviously doing to just undo the last
Jedi and so I'm saying like I want to
rewatch the film again to see if I truly
agree with you on certain things because
obviously hearing from this like SI
perspectives easy to be persuaded so I'd
love to go and watch the movie again to
be like hey you know what cinema wins
was right because there are things here
that seem to
actually flow and be in connectivity
with the last Jedi as opposed to undoing
them that seemed with Luke Skywalker did
get a lot of flack in rise of Skywalker
for being a whole thing that's kind of a
big fu to the portrayal of Mark Hamill's
Luke Skywalker in the last Jedi you're
absolutely correct he does arc in that
movie he does realize he was wrong
that's the whole point of Mark Hamill's
arc in the last Jedi of a guy who's lost
all his faith in everything and then he
finds his faith and again by the end of
it so him saying he's wrong is not
necessarily undoing the last Jedi that
is going off of what happened in the
last gen confirming the arc yeah for him
to come back as a force ghost it's nice
to have him in that light because one
thing that I thought you did really well
throughout this whole video knowing when
the movie is tying it in to previous
philosophies that were established
especially with Yoda and Empire Strikes
Back talking about like the force
healing and whatnot really paying
attention to how this is linking through
the force awakens in the last Jedi it
seemed like you really were able to
grasp on to what this trilogy was about
and what this trilogy was aiming to
thematically explore and expound upon
also tie into the original trilogy
especially I think my appreciation for
this film was really enhanced I think
the releases on may the fourth be with
you day it is perfect because it's nice
that for the last Skywalker film and
dealing with reception and backlash and
being exposed to it all and oftentimes
putting your own opinion out there that
seems to sometimes my opinion sound
contradictory because there are things I
really enjoyed about it and there's I
really didn't like and it's fun to go
you know what there definitely is a lot
to appreciate about this right that's
like little things such as when they go
and they see the whole parade of stuff
happening I watched the cinema since one
of my own time then he was pointing out
how come they couldn't hear all that
music and people dancing until they got
over the hill who like could they do
that from far away and so my mind's like
gosh a frickin movie what the hell this
bringing up how it makes the galaxy feel
lived in again that it's not just
desolate warzone
territories and blah blah blah as an
actual culture yeah to see for a little
bit it brings a layer of beauty and
wonder back to it now granted I keep
bringing this up I don't know if I'll
feel that again when I'm watching the
actual movie but at least in terms of
looking at the context I do appreciate
that and the other thing that I thought
was really powerful that you brought up
was the connection building between kylo
Ren and Ray of how this trilogy has been
setting up from the beginning them being
like these opposing figures who have a
connection and it's all leading up to
them using their connection together to
defeat the evil every trilogy is always
about light versus dark to have them
come together and then the lightsaber
being a symbolism of sorts but I also
appreciate your humor too of just
knowing whenever like screw it this is
funny your skirt this looks badass all
right just let it be because I think
there's something to be said about that
shipwreck fight scene how like great and
cool it is but how the stakes can feel a
little bit subdued because you're like
yeah you know this isn't gonna be the
final fight you know this isn't gonna
lead to one of them truly dying seeing
the symbolism and what that leads to
mamie love that fight even a whole lot
more there's plenty of things you can
still criticize there are things you
definitely did not touch on leave that
to cinemasins yeah their countless
criticisms we've heard this video is
about appreciating what this movie did
right and perhaps bring in a different
perspective on certain elements going
against certain critiques from this
viewing experience
I think you've succeeded I quite love
this it just feels good to feel good
about Rises gotta walk back to the
immediate experience of watching it
because in the theater I had a really
fun time you know the ensemble vibe is
really fun and enjoyable and there's
some really dazzling action some really
dazzling visuals and I think that once
we get away from how important it is
that all these movies are terrific yeah
maybe we'll all be able to enjoy them
with a little bit more relaxed you know
uh inclusivity true mean yeah I could go
on and on about a lot of things that you
pointed out a lot of them are really
more little Chewbacca like the fake-out
and a lot of people harped on that I
think we even did of just how like there
was no real breath there
but I don't know it might have been one
of those fake-out yeah I don't know if I
could meet you there actually yeah it's
more for raised character than it is for
us but I would just argue that it should
have worked both ways because if it's
gonna be a worthwhile emotional beat we
got to feel the emotion of the beat yeah
that's true that's a good point
cinema wins a fantastic job I really am
grateful for this video today and this
move me yeah ed so thank you for putting
this together
subscribe to cinema ones if you haven't
done so already it's good to have
something positive in your life like
this channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects click our notification will
get notified whenever we've got a new
youtube video up check us out on patreon
of course last but not least we have to
shout out the person on our patreon page
who undoubtably is the biggest star Wars
fan over at our patreon
that's TJ trakis at EJ we've given a lot
of goofy shoutouts and everything I just
wanted to say to you today that I'm very
grateful to have you on our page very
grateful to have you in our lives and I
hope you and your family are able to be
safe during this time that the force is
strong within your family today crystal
your wife seems like a really strong
warrior and you seem like a a nice
tender sensitive father but your junk
traitors your nobodies undercut my
sincerity with a joke I didn't mean to
be funny oh yeah you didn't succeed
either
it's Skyler and your daughter I'll just
say when you're 18 come find me when
you're 18 I hope you still got your
rebel goatee there TJ I don't know your
daughter she talked Matt I don't know
what to say about her oh she's a good
baby